(upbeat music)
- There it is. (laughs)
My music taste, well,
before college I would actually
say all music, but country.
But I went to college in Missouri,
so I like country music
as well, a little bit now.
Music's a reflection of who we are,
and maybe this is a way to just
have an organic relationship
that you get to connect to which is music.
So yeah.
- [Host] Are you excited?
- I am beyond excited.
Ladies, are y'all excited?
- [Contestants] Yes.
(everyone laughing)
- I love that.
(upbeat music)
Oh, it's got that good bass.
Aye.
(Kendall chuckles)
Fire. Great taste for sure.
So that's the right vibe
right there for sure.
That little Anderson .Paak feel to it.
So it's special for sure.
- [Host] What can you
infer about contestant one
from that song?
- That they probably
play it cool, you know?
They probably the person
sitting there watching everyone
just jamming out and stuff like that.
So yeah.
(slow chill music)
You gotta be careful, baby.
They grow on the same
wave right now, everyone.
I like those type of
people that just you know,
they know how to obviously get lit,
but just when they're
calm throughout the day
and just know how to go with the flow.
(bright upbeat music)
I think that's a lot of people's anthem.
Not over the top happy,
but just a joyful just experience to life.
(slow mellow music)
That one was a lot deeper for sure.
There's just those certain songs you play,
and you have to just kind of pause,
and just really listen
to what it's saying,
and that one for sure hit the soul.
(slow hiphop music)
Can't go wrong with Kendrick for sure.
I could picture all these
girls probably just maybe chaos
or people running around,
and they're just in their own
zone, enjoying themselves.
(upbeat dance music)
Yo, that one made me feel good.
You know like, enjoying
my day, I got work done.
I'm going home to some good food.
I'm just jamming, hanging out,
so I love that one.
(beep)
(suspenseful music)
Okay. I'm gonna do one,
and only because the
decision was probably more
out of the more chill songs.
Yeah.
(contestants chuckle)
- Hi, how's it going?
- Hi.
Good. How are you?
- Doing well.
Sorry about that.
- It's all good.
I mean, not a fan of Anderson .Paak.
It's okay.
- No, I am. No, I am.
- Oh, you are?
- I am a hundred percent.
I just, you know, all
the ones had a little
just a little something different.
- Yeah, okay. Beautiful.
- Sorry.
- All good.
(beep)
- Contestant six,
what's like your love song,
like your mad song?
Maybe you just got in a
relationship, what would that be?
(bright romantic song)
So why this song?
- [Nalu] I love to dance,
and I love to dance with
a person who I love.
- I love that.
- [Nalu] Do you like to dance?
- I do.
I just got done from
a festival doing that.
- [Jordan] Wait, romance
or falling in love?
Let's do like you're falling in love.
- [Jordan] Okay.
(bright romantic song)
- What does this song make you feel?
- [Jordan] I can picture
myself like stargazing
to this song, and it's
just such a classic.
- Let's do number, contestant four.
What's that pump up song for you?
Like I don't know about
to get in at the gym.
(upbeat hiphip music)
Okay. (laughs)
Okay, okay.
Are you throwing up
gang signs to this song?
- [Bazzy] No.
- You know, getting lit?
Like what's that look like for you?
- [Bazzy] No, not at all.
- No, not at all?
(contestants laugh)
- [Bazzy] This is definitely like,
I'm at the gym, I need motivation.
- Okay. Let's do breakup song.
- [Iman] It's 10 minutes. (laughs)
- Oh, okay. Let's go.
(dramatic music)
- [Iman] This is the
best part of the song.
Wait, hold up. Listen.
(Iman chuckles)
(Ray laughs)
- I love it. Okay.
- [Iman] So the entire song,
- Okay.
- [Iman] all 10 minutes of it,
is just a roller coaster of emotions.
It's Taylor swift. (chuckles)
The way that she writes
it's just such a powerful, like emotion.
- I, I'm not a Swifty.
It's for sure I think an acquired taste.
Can we do crying in your car song?
(somber music)
How many times a week do you
feel like you use this song?
- [Lola] Several times a week. (chuckles)
- Okay. I feel that I understand.
What does this song make you feel?
- [Lola] I don't know.
That's a good question.
I feel like it could go either way,
depending on the mood I'm in.
I definitely can stay there
and sit with that song,
but with the emotion of her voice
(beep)
(suspenseful music)
(Ray chuckles)
- It's really hard.
I will eliminate contestant number three.
I don't know. It's like
some of the other ones
have intrigued me more
just the music choices.
- [Iman] Hi.
- Hi. How's it going?
- Good. How are you?
- Good. I'm sorry about that.
- You're okay.
- But we love Taylor Swift
and it's a good song though.
- I wish you heard some
of my other music though.
I'm a punk rocker.
- Punk rocks.
- Love it. Yeah.
- Okay.
Eliminate number five.
- [Lola] Hi.
- Hi. How's it going?
- Good. How are you?
- Sorry about that.
I love your hair by the way.
- Thank you.
Nice to meet you.
- Powerful. Yeah.
So sorry about that.
- It's fine. It was a good song.
- I know, I know.
I know. (laughs)
- [Lola] Whatever.
(beep)
(lively music)
We for sure at the family
barbecue right now. (chuckles)
Yeah. What does this song mean to you?
- So my dad used to DJ in the 80's.
It was playing in our
living room all the time,
and like anytime I hear it now
I'm just like, "Okay, I gotta dance."
You know?
- I get it.
And then the ad libs of the song,
like they're just so funny.
He's like, (imitates ad libs).
- Yeah. No, I got you.
Who's like your top
played artist right now?
- I think it was Glass Animals.
And then Drake, because I'm from Toronto.
(lively music)
- Very good.
So who's this artist of this song?
- [Bazzy] Her name is Fairuz.
She's a Lebanese singer
from like the 60's I think.
I'm Lebanese, so this kind
of hits close to home.
- Yeah.
- [Bazzy] Me and my parents
would play this a lot, and
it would kind of get us
out of our negative head space.
- Got you.
- [Bazzy] It makes me miss
my family back home.
- Got you.
Do you, do you do any like
creative stuff with music
and stuff like that, or?
- [Bazzy] I DJ, I make mixes.
I work in radio, and I also play guitar.
Music is definitely a huge
part of my creative process
in everyday life.
- Yeah.
Sweet. Thank you.
- [Bazzy] Mm-hmm.
(slow jazz music)
- So what kind of, inclined
you to pick this song?
- [Nalu] Yeah, I'm from South Africa,
and we've got a huge jazz community there.
We've got jazz festivals that we go to
as a family all the time.
- I know. So obviously it's very opposite
of the first music you played.
- [Nalu] Yes.
- What would you say is your
normal day to day music though?
- [Nalu] I wake up in the
morning and I listen to jazz
like Billie Holiday,
Etta James, Julie London.
While I'm getting done
like for a night out,
I'd listen to like baddie music, I guess.
Like SZA, and like you know.
- Yeah, it's your core.
- [Nalu] Just to get me feeling myself.
You know, Jhene Aiko.
- For me, I think one
of my inspos is just,
I guess a lot of Ray Charles
and Nancy Blues.
- [Nalu] Oh, fire.
- So it's actually pretty
interesting for you
to play this song, so yeah.
No, thank you. I appreciate that.
(beep)
(suspenseful music)
Super hard. (chuckles)
Eliminate number two.
Hi. How's it going?
I'm sorry about that.
- It's okay.
- I love your tattoos by the way.
Those are fire.
- Thank you.
- I love your music as well.
Like, oh, your dad's a DJ?
Yeah?
- I like your style. It's cool.
- Thank you. Appreciate that.
(Ray chuckles)
We'll be eliminating.
(suspenseful music)
I eliminate number four.
- [Bazzy] Hi.
- Hi. How's it going?
- [Bazzy] I'm good. How are you?
- I love your style by the way.
- Thank you.
- It's fire.
- I like your style too.
I'm Bazzy.
- Love your choices.
Obviously I can tell you're into radio,
and stuff like that, and music, so.
- All good.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- All right. Have a good one.
- [Host] Are you ready
to meet her face to face?
- Yeah. (chuckles)
Yeah.
(bright upbeat music)
- [Nalu] Hi.
- Hey, how's it going?
- [Nalu] I'm good. I'm Nalu.
- I'm Ray.
- Yeah, I'm sorry.
- I love your style.
- Hi.
- What was your?
- Nalu.
- Yeah.
- It's beautiful.
I love that one.
- Thank you.
I like your name
- Thank you. Appreciate that.
- You're the one killing them all.
- Thank you. Thank you.
That's dope. So you like my music?
- I do. It's so different.
And I don't know.
It pulls me outta my shell a little bit.
So I think I can vibe with that.
- That's dope. That's dope.
Do you like make music or work in music?
- I work with a lot of
music artists, so yeah.
- I'm a music artist.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Love that.
I love to hear some more music.
- Yeah, I'll send you my Spotify.
- Of course, of course.
- [Host] Are we gonna get her number?
- Of course. I'm gonna try.
You know.
So you want dancing, dancing,
like we're at a festival.
- Like whatever.
Whatever you think I
would like to dance to.
No pressure.
- That's a lot of pressure.
(both laughing)
(upbeat dance music)
- Wow. (laughs)
- Sorry. I know, I know.
- I wasn't expecting that.
(both laughing)
No, no, no. It's fine.
You're good, you're good.
He seems like he has a like
a really like sweet vibe
and like dope vibe.
But to be honest with
you I don't think that,
I think him and I could be
like really dope like homies.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Oh it's fine.
(upbeat dance music)
I'm waiting for the break.